قبل ان اجيب على هذا السؤال دعيني اؤكد لك
بان مناطق شمال غرب سوريا الواقعه تحت
سيطره المعارضه لم يدخل اليها اي شحنه من
المساعدات ومن الامم المتحده ومفوضيه شؤون
اللاجئين او الهلال
لانه ممنوعين كلها كانت الامم المتحده
تتحدث عنه يعني يعني وجود شحنات من
المساعدات عالقه على الطرف التركي واوعزت
الاسباب الى امور اللوجستيه هناك رغبه
بمساعده المناطق المنكوبه لكن الطقس
القطاع الطرقات كما يعرف غسان في مناطق
التركيه في الولايات العاشر المتضرره تعيق
يعني او تؤخر على الاقل دخول هذه
المساعدات الى هذه المناطق لكن ردا على
سؤالك ميسون نعم يعني ليس هناك حل سوى
مطار دمشق الدولي سوى نوالئ اللاذقيه هذه
الموانئ تقع تحت سيطره النظام لا يوجد
اتفاق سياسي بين المعارضه والنظام
وبالتالي هذه الاشكاليه
عرق الجهود ادخال المساعدات الى المناطق
المنكوبه خاصه في ادلب والارياف الشماليه
والغربيه لحلب كما تفضلت مطار حلب يبقى
الحل الافضل في حال لو استطاعت الدول
المانحه والجهات المعنيه ايجاد صيغه تفاهم
مع الطرفين المعارضه ونظام لخلق جسم جوي
لاثقال المساعدات عبر وهو اعتقد الطريقه
الانجح